[Music]
let's go all the way back to one of my
favorite years 1985 and talk about
Russia today there's so much happening
in the news lately with this giant
country but since we're all in election
mode here in the United States pretty
much all the time most of the news about
Russia is getting completely lost and
there's a bunch going on
first there's the ongoing war with
Russia and Syria which has become the
deadliest conflict since World War two
it's estimated that over 400,000 people
have died so far and sadly it seems that
there's no light at the end of the
tunnel
then there's the rumors that WikiLeaks
is somehow working with the Russian
government to influence our election
right here this has become a big talking
point in democratic circles as WikiLeaks
continues to drop information about
Hillary Clinton emails and Clinton
foundation donors even Julian Assange
WikiLeaks editor-in-chief is promising
more October surprises and clearly
they're not going to be aimed at helping
Hillary or the Democrats on top of those
issues there's a lot of other reasons to
believe that Vladimir Putin sees America
in retreat around the world and he's
looking to fill that void Russia has
occupied Ukraine for two years now and
it's clear that Russia is making moves
throughout Syria without US approval
sometimes in direct conflict with
American goals although it's completely
unclear to me what exactly those
American goals are only four years ago
in America's last presidential election
Mitt Romney was widely mocked for
calling Russia without question our
number one geopolitical oh and yet now
it seems that it's the Democrats who are
leaning more hawkish on Russia just
listen to Hillary or Tim Kaine in the
debate so far the Democratic nominees
are much more anti Russia than either
Trump or Pence is Trump too close to
Putin or does he have other Russian
business interests in mind
I guess that's possible too there could
be a new cold war brewing but this time
there may not be a Rocky Balboa verse
Ivan Drago boxing match on Christmas Day
in Moscow to help us work things out
well I don't think there's any
legitimate reason that a direct conflict
with Russia is on the way I do think
it's
important that we start talking about
our deeply complex relationship with
Russia in an open and honest way not
just by demonizing and making fun of
Putin which don't get me wrong he makes
it very easy to do but by really
understanding what's going on within
Russia and the geopolitical
circumstances which have led us to where
we are now if we don't do a little
homework now
then we'll all be easily manipulated by
both politicians as well as by the media
that has their own goals in mind
boogeymen are a lot less scary when you
know a little bit about them my guest
this week is author and columnist Kathy
Kathy grew up in Russia until the age of
16 when she moved to the United States
she's written for the New York Times The
Washington Post The Wall Street Journal
as well as my hometown newspaper Newsday
she focuses on some of my favorite
topics including political correctness
and free speech and from what I've seen
she equally calls out the bad elements
of both the regressive left and the all
right she's also been an outspoken
critic of modern feminism and a defender
of the men's rights movement though she
sees some issues with that movement as
well
I view Cathy is one of the few people
really trying to take both sides to task
and give both sides a chance before
forming her own opinions all the while
not being too attached to a specific
ideology not being locked in to a
specific ideology and being
intellectually flexible is one of the
most important attributes you can have
and one that I consistently strive to
have for myself the last few months have
been interesting as we've seen many
never Trump Republicans slowly fall in
line to a lesser degree we've seen it
with the Bernie bros who seem far less
inclined to go all in for Hillary the
wider point here though is that everyone
is making their own calculations and
decisions based on the information
around them the key no matter what you
believe is to have access to new ideas
and concepts and to have conversations
that will either enforce your beliefs or
change them for the better
you
[Music]